alexiens est ce que tu nous entends à je
vous entends c'est un peu l'émission de
l'invité bissett
est-ce que donc c'est toujours ok pour
venir rejoindre l'équipe est ainsi le
devenir la sixième membres de cette
bande d'aventuriers
france du professionnalisme évidemment
je vous rejoins
faire comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le mois
lighting m
[Musique]
catharines
[Applaudissements]
c'est vous dire à fait pris un peu de
producteurs et productrices utile aux
français s'ils mouillerai le maillot
comme ça pour une émission vraiment
profondément quoi asie vraiment rejoint
passe muraille en absence de données et
l'équipement pense évidemment on n'est
pas candidat comme ça on les candidats
parce qu'on l'a aussi l'équipement qui
lie la lutte est avant tout
très contente j'adore faire de la télé
j'adore rentrée en espérant ne pas être
un boulet
mais j'ai des gars qui sont assurés
qu'ils valent une fortune
je vais te tuer les cheveux noirs
en quatre langues mathias pogba promet
des révélations explosives sur son frère
cadet j'estime que c'est espagnol
anglais ce qui veut dire augmenter mais
de savoir certaines choses afin de
décider en toute connaissance de cause
s'il arrive vraiment d'admiration le
respect
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une vidéo énigmatique dans laquelle
l'ancien attaquant de 32 ans aujourd'hui
sans club vise également la puissante
avocate du champion du monde rafaï
lappeerenta
aussi
par les travées boufféré sur son
intégrité et son professionnalisme
après tout il ya eu un match retour en
turquie à un gc nice a perdu 2 0 mais
qui est lé buteur turc
à 6 ans et non pas six mais comment tu
peux faire je me souvienne je retiens
c'était le cas les rangs un indice il
est proche moi je me suis fait de la
remontée
j'ai lu non mais en stru il n'y a qu'un
seul buteur a selon des proches de la
famille de fortes sommes d'argent
auraient été réclamée à paul pogba pour
empêcher la diffusion de vidéos
prétendument compromettantes mathias
pogba promet aussi des révélations sur
le chouchou des bleus qu'ils vient le
bape et aura des éléments de langage
pour conférer les vocaux tout ça puisque
explosif et de
raser la barbe en direct en direct j'ai
perdu ma barbe parce que j'ai pas trouvé
le buteur turc match retour face à
l'agencé nice aurait mieux fait d'aller
au match retour nos matchs à l'aise
qu'en turquie à 11 en bresse avec
plaisir je suis désolé la france y sont
devant moi la radio ce que vous en savez
j'ai très peur qu'il ay lui couper la
carotide le bruit d'une tondeuse voilà
je suis en train de me faire raser la
barbe parce que j'ai perdu
un pari vous allez bien très bien ok
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans la vie mais
vous venez d'où je suis responsable
administrative et je viens de maurepas
dans les yvelines à maurepas très bien
voilà laurent non responsable et nice
traduit dans quoi dans un centre de
traitement et d'un plan kaki
pourquoi vous rigolez
je vends pas les cheveux quoi
c'est pas possible c est ce que je me
demande si c'est pas une première c'est
un rasage en direct comme sa religion
alors en fait olivier m'avait déjà teint
les cheveux en rouge si vous vous
souvenez avec une bombe pied de feed
c'était la coupe de france et j'avais
dit que le psg
high rise à moustache et rabâché
horrible
m'accuse-t-on ma culture 420 qu'ils 17
points points on est le début
philippe et la mort
[Musique]
quel pilote britannique détient sept
titres de champion de f1 lewis hamilton
dr cantin fille au maillet tig et les
cinq médailles lors des jo de la ville
jean-louis avec quoi les joueurs de polo
frappe-t-il la balle avec leurs clubs à
maillé